All right. My name is Diane
and library
with a. And it for the
AFI
that I find great. I had.
Oh well. I want to first start by thanking you for giving me the privilege of being a part of such a
wonderful idea and a great program as many many times and we do a lot of things that
are recorded and not enough times
that people realize they exist and this is a great way to have a legacy for the
library and to people use it.
So I was born about eight blocks from this building on the quantum East eighty third
Street and Glenn McGrath. And I grew up my entire
adult life and Canarsie which is where that
is and I had. My grandparents came in one
thousand nineteen in this fight
I'm telling you about and my grandfather had a farm that pretty much started about four or
five blocks from here ran along. And was
about two or three acres in that size at the time. And knows bass
Canarsie was a very unique place if it had its built up area which was built in
you're only nineteen twenty's in the late teens early
twenty's and then they had what they called the back and the back was the area from back east
eighty eight st the routes have you from four storey M.-U. all the way
down to Pataky creek over here to all those areas south of
Flatland
Sammy and I was called back because it really had almost no homes that a
bunch of summer bungalows. And those bungalows remaining inhabited
by Sicilian Italians who came from Ridgewood
Brooklyn and that was on the L. Y. Now many people see they hear about the El train today.
What most people don't know is the el train originating to actually
originally started in at the foot of.
Seaview pier. Which is down on the end of Rockaway Park when the Bell
Parkway and this was a time when there was no Belt Parkway and that area was in
fact an amusement
park from the late eighteenth hundreds into around the late one nine hundred twenty
S.
and it was called Golden City amusement park and the train
actually ran to where it is now Mark with Buckley now and then you switch to a trolley
that roll all the way down Rockaway Parkway actually at the time the train
when in the middle of a whole bunch of empty land that
was called
the Long Island where recut that still there are many places and then
was replaced by the trolley on Rockaway Parkway. So this is a pretty pretty much
rule where you're with had a lot of Tang an immigrant who's utilized
it and it was there some a Holmes lived over in Ridgewood or
Bushwick he lived in these four story frame walkups with no fans and no air conditioning
and none of the amenities we have today and this was like their way of coming to the country and
it reminded them of the place that they originated
from so that became my home in the home of about forty seven of my
relatives my immediate relatives. So I can remember a time when
I had. All of my aunts and uncles all of my first
cousins whole my friends live within that little. Six black area
from Fram's around C.N.N. New down
to maybe eighty was now eighty H.P.D. stadia street
some square think so my connection with this library is pretty much goes back to when the day it
was built.
Prior to this library the built in the one nine hundred sixty S. by the way to a very I think was one thousand nine
hundred fifty S. that purpose whatever you know we had no I marries in this
area the closest library was the Canarsie library which was located back then on
Glenwood
road and east ninety fifth Street and it stared at the building this tall
there today and right next to it was the sixty one precinct police. Freezing which
also was at that that site until an early one nine hundred seventy S..
So it's a real connection road as a real connection and I'm really saying I'm Islam because
back in those days.
We didn't have a glamour road it ended at a state third Street and there was no Farragut row
because that ended at least eighty seven street. So we would walk to empty
fields and pets to come here that was building a coming of I call you walk here.
And that went on right pretty much so pretty
close to the end of the one nine hundred fifty S. before they actually built began
building what we call the new homes which all these brick attached homes are in
these blocks
surrounding Patta get library when the library was built there was maybe
only it was a housing project where we now we call it there are other things where Glenwood
houses was here which is built in one nine hundred forty nine and almost nothing else.
I mean literally it was a housing development and then the library
in this hall and them
had crossed away from the library was an amusement park.
Miniature amusement park where they had kiddie rides and things like that and
where satisfied south to high school is now which is right across from the
library on my family you know that was empty lots that was utilized for junk
yards
and the Kona being what was kind of old fashioned they use called the rodeo Grill which is
great an old fashioned hamburger place. Out of there so it's a pretty unique place to live and
back that.
And that the only thing you knew for sure you were in this area was give us a pedicure treat
pumping station which is also visible from the library. OK would usually belch
out its fumes as the waters came through and all the sewers would come through into
the creek.
So we had a pretty nice place where you can get you've got the sights the sounds and the smells
of all of our neighborhood sanding the front of the paddock in the library.
So now reason why the library is important to me. Well I think that's a
mother question. So I
was going to be doing
fine in the
past three
that.
I
was I was very young when they had been in the E.U. I must've been about ten years old when they actually built
this library in the late fifty's. And and we were
all excited because it was finally a place that was close by that we could
utilize and you know back in the one nine hundred fifty S. and sixty's and
I guess we can go right up into the
ninety's there really wasn't many of the ways to have an ability
to learn except through
books and the books that the library how was a true poet
the treasure that all of us looked. Because we didn't have
any exceptions had what they called an
encyclopedia back then you a lucky if your family could afford us an encyclopedia
and other than that you'd have to come to the library ferry resource that you needed to
school. And it was unique for me because I would go to. At
the time I went to. Job Wilson High School which is located on
these two hundred street again in the middle of it totally and the area of
land was a school belt and we have the choice of either
going to the Canarsie library on our way home or if we were home. Over to
this library to be able to do our stunning.
Some Now why this place. Now I can tell you that the rest of the area was also as rule
as Iraq's plane to go with
the RAF every new area that shopping centers that are here now weren't there. There was
a miniature golf course that was on there and the first substantial building that was
built is what's now D.P.C. Rich's building which was really begin
Hodge's bowing out that was built.
But there was no Georgetown which is the neighborhood that.
West. He stuck to our fare on the raft ever your side South Platte when there
was no Futurama which is the area that's out the flat lands on this side of
Rafa ever you know meaning the west
side and flat lands which is this is the area that the library
is part of was really just beginning to be developed so we had
the entire We had Glenwood
houses and a lot of empty lots and slowly was surely in the fifty's.
We saw this area develop of much homes we wanted to family homes being built.
So that what makes what houses so unique was when wood houses along
with Seaview Bayview houses and Brookline houses
were three housing developments that
were built here in this community and all three of them were built for
returning veterans who had served in World War
two and to try and help and assist in this really
really shortage of housing that was needed for all these millions of soldiers who came
home and now began starting their families and they were all built about the same time in the late
one nine hundred forty S.
and a very very a project was mine a mental look at it today because they
started building in one thousand forty six forty seven and they were completed by the one nine hundred forty nine.
When do you see anything get done that fast. But they all
managed to take the
veterans mostly better ones who are serving in more war two
and becoming homes for their families. And going with us continue to be that kind
of
place. So. Now my connection with Grandma goes back a little bit more because
back in one thousand nine hundred sixty five.
When I first graduated high school and I needed to get a job in January one thousand nine hundred
eleven from climate and I had this great opportunity a friend of mine was
the manager of a
bank and he said to me he would offer me a job that paid
seventy five. That was a week.
This in one thousand nine hundred eighty
five and I had to wear a suit and tie every day and pretty much have to
worry about where I was going to have
lunch and how to get it to the bank itself was a little bit out of the neighborhood.
And another friend had worked here as well we called a supervisor a
foreman in Glenwood houses in that and they had an opening for what they call
the caretakers position.
And they can take it someone basically is a janitor who cleans the buildings as a project and they
had an opening they have a pay that paid eighty five dollars a week.
Plus overtime on the weekends and they get an extra twenty dollars a week twenty five
dollars a week and from working. Clubs. It was very low they gave you the forms and
I could walk here every day from my
home. So what could be better than that and so there I was England Woodhouse's
working in one thousand January one thousand nine hundred sixty
five That began my career my real love affair with this
library help. I've had many many careers since that
day in one thousand nine hundred sixty five but the one that was propelled
me to some of the things I am to now was a result of my ability to use this
library had a good branch was an island of
sanity in their world of so much conflict and it will be a place I
would come to have every day at
lunchtime to take and study for the various simple service exams that were
given for the police the fire the sanitation many of the
other civil service jobs. That were out there that I would do that is I would take
the
books. From here from the library that they had then they would study books for these
tests and every day come and sit here and take the test with credit
to pretend to repeat
them and without exaggeration I did that pretty much about eight or nine months before the
test came on. And because of my efforts here and the help by the way of the
librarians and others who are very very. In those days and still are now very
very qualified people and I wound up
becoming my aunt and I took the test and I had if you understand
the civil service list the higher the number you are in the
list the better chance you have a B. of appointment.
So I was number twenty seven. Out of thousands on the New York City Police
Department
as I was number nine on the housing back then there were different police departments.
I was number nine on the Housing Police West number seventeen on the transit
police list and number thirty on the fire department less.
So I did very very well and that's only because I was able to come here each
day and have the solitude of this environment to be able
to take those tests and study for and work
on time and time again until I was well prepared when the
time came that I had to take the actual exam.
I wound up getting called for the police department York City Police Department first
and I took that position because it was the first one to be called
and I don't know if the others would have called me I'm a great believer in faith
and
destiny and I think that was my destiny to be on that particular
police department and I was was a very successful career for me as a result.
So there I am right here in that I had to write all the age of twenty in nine months.
Being very excited about working for two years and when would have was and
then work studying here each
day and finding that the result of that was led to the beginning of
my career in public service.
Had a lot.
When my friend I have many many friends in this community. So if
you as a matter of fact anybody who comes from this new huge comes to my house around
Christmas
time. Because I put up a few Christmas light flatlands Avenue in these ninety
third Street where are you moved to for a while and we put up an
entire Christmas display that is the most renowned Christmas display in the
city and they are over three hundred fifty thousand dollars worth of Christmas
decorations and. All kind of animated dolls and all kinds
of different. Window displays that are
a great great pleasure for the kids to look at and we just open those lights
on Wednesday on Sunday
night and I've done that for the twenty ninth year in a row that I've been doing
it and I haven't done private Minas much smaller scale.
So this is a from a neighborhood where I grew up in a neighborhood which have great regard
for and great deal of love and passion for a neighborhood that
has constantly been the
source of a current people. What's wonderful you know although this is what they
call the Patty good library really is the extension of the Canarsie
community and these communities and always been middle income communities and mostly
middle income immigrants people who've gone to that first opportunity to buy
their first
home. And that's what's so exciting about it many times is that we have people generation after
generation of immigrants from all over the world originally started with the Dutch we
can around and say you know the Canarsie in the is we here. And they were first here
and they dealt with the
Dutch back then selling them pieces of land that they didn't even own but they
took them anyway and had the original Dutch settlers set here and this
entire
community. This was farmland for many many many years and it's hard
to perceive today because the different things that occurred in the end the allow men to have a
have a community generations are
such That's how it started and then it went and then it continued on
to the English and then in this particular there was a very large
German and. German community the chain here and then finally in
the fifty's and thirty's and twenty's and thirty's
were
Italians and then it developed into and then it became as
the
communities continued to grow and change or became the Jewish. A
large Jewish community that had moved south from Brownsville in East New
York and today it's
probably the most middle income Caribbean community in the city of New
York. We have I think forty seven different countries
represented a
currency from every island in the Caribbean.
Including that one that's way far over to the east Sicily.
Well
growing up it was a great adventure I went to public school one fourteen years which is on Remsen Avenue and when
we're broke. Now if you think of lumber OK Well marauders one of the last outposts in this part of
the world but it was one of the few streets that went down to the state Eritrea which is
where we live and it was a
paved lemon grove where I live was in pains until the mid fifty's
around fifty
seven fifty eight fifty eight I think it was before it actually was paved as
a paved street and had sidewalks. So you can imagine that we would use that it
was wonderful because I'm a road at the state search it was the end of the page to me.
So everything we used to have maybe a car
come down about one hour. As compared to when you see the traffic that's that I and
that was basically our Paul
field and. We would spend many Some I can remember being ten
years old and finding an intersection of what's now east eighty fourth Street
of M. world a very large guy today. Under a rock had took it home
as my pet for a long period of time. That's the kind of community this
was and most of what happened was in the one nine hundred forty S. the late one nine hundred forty S..
The sewer system.
There was no school system here until that tight and the sewer system was
developed and it was and it was six and it was already here.
And we had that's what raises what we call raised the street if you ever drive
to some of the side streets my road just noticed that when I came down you'll see that a lot of the homes that are built.
They have these low tried ways they have answers to the back yard and that's
because that was the level of the street at the time.
So we didn't have the street was that
wall and they were and only for the stay put in the source
just now what that did was two things was it leveled off all the streets to the level that there
are today what we call street level and it took all that farmland that I told you
about and really made it
a like a rabid and
then open land and made these in Manc meant to cause all of this man to just
sit sit there and really not be utilized as much for the farmland. Because
what would happen when it rains it was the water goes down and it became very swampy.
So a good part of this area was swamp in those days because of that so. So a really
interesting place to grow up a site grown up in the country.
And our greatest thing will be I can remember being ten years old going over what is
now Pataky creek and trying a bunch of logs together and grabbing the snow along tree
limb and actually sailing out on the floating out on the
creek to about four or five dogs try to get of Iraq pretty much like Tom Sawyer
that on the Mississippi so we have and then this is our experience and
of course we never ever bought a scalding ball.
Now that's maybe an unheard of thing want to score mostly on the water Spalding dollars but it's
a rubber ball that you play handle weight or anything like that and the reason we didn't is because
all the sewers emptied into Pataky creek and Spring Creek back then.
So you would find a new every gets Spalding balls floating all over the.
Place and we will be taking them out washing them off and they became our play toys last
that and there are a lot of dumps here. Those days flatten and then you
wear where the school is now or or really
legitimate dumps dumping places for from debris and
things and I got my first bicycle
out of the pile in Flatland
venue
where we where is that memory got my first car out of their
junkyard flatlands area what's now probably the entrance to the south
to high
school I remember right now nine hundred sixty five my about I got a nine
hundred fifty six Ford Fairlane convertible for fifty dollars.
That was the cost of the car the insurance was two hundred cost more than the car
itself and I would drive that car around it was not like being a thousand years only a
convertible and the neighborhood in those days and that was a great great pleasure. Said a lot of fun
with that.
Hi I was. We went to Tilden high school because there was no Canarsie high school was out
from high school and if you lived in this area or Brooklyn. Brockway park was like
a border like. If you lived East in Rockaway
Parkway meaning going out towards towards East New York. You went to Thomas Jefferson High School.
If you lived where asked Brockley park where you went to tell that high school. Those are the
only two high schools and we had what we call triple session back then of
course community had grown so
large that we would have three and four thousand students in school itself.
I think my graduating class was like eight hundred fifty or nine hundred students.
At the time when I graduated high school. So you can imagine that today most schools aren't
that pick high schools but that was the way it was that.
And we all graduated everybody graduated at a low is King's Theatre was just reopened by the
way have always kings of flappers having I am all road hand it just.
We opened that day as a theater venue but that was the place everyone went to
graduate us was the only building big enough to accommodate those large classes
of students and their parents. Has been a pretty nice experience crowd
there. What's that
all broken cars been around since the thirty's as a matter fact problem cause where I went to
school I went at night to Brooklyn
College and it took me fifteen years to graduate but I did it I
started when I was in my early twenty's and graduated when I was thirty five so thirty
years
ago I had a ripple we went at night. Back then if you had you work during the day it was one
of your school's and off night classes and we were all and thanks to a thing called open enrollment.
I was able to go back in your own seventies when I first thought I couldn't go to school when I first
graduated high school because counts because my family was very
poor and I needed to work in order to help assist my
mom and my other five brothers and sisters.
So my dad had been gone for quite a while by then.
And we my mom
re six kids by herself in that same well as still there.
I remember I just passed it and I saw that someone helping the stupid in the
front who talked about building that's two for about fifty years and somebody actually just below
on my way here Sal and trusting
that. Every once in a while I stop by here just talking past and see what it looks like.
And I have my entire family living in like a three block area. My uncles and aunts and I
are everybody and everybody knew everybody.
It was not like you could do anything in this neighborhood wrong was that we wanted to tell your grandmother your mother
or your rant or something. You know
and we had no buses in the ninth in the nineteen fifties.
The only buses we had here are ten
R.C. was the beast that was the sixty Wilson which came down
Rockaway Park white.
Had traveled. And to merge with the Bushwick. And we
had. Seventeen Remsen which
left from Utica revenue in Eastern Parkway and came down again ended at
the rock right proper train station which And now finds an M U two routes one that went up
to when the road and then up to her right train station and the other went that the Seaview
Avenue down to maybe you have this.
And that was it. There was no other buses and tell the white ones the mid sixty's that thing when we got to
be six we were all excited we had an actual bus to go to another part of Brooklyn.
And today we have about nine bus lines and it's very
interesting to say and this is a community I truly
grew had a New York of as New York City grew so did you know I stand there and
the empath flatlands in the Patton area. It's
absolutely. Great place to grow up. It was it was
like being in your own country home. Awesome a lot.
The three of us to one is in Florida and to live in I call
it cupcake like one Kancha like one can come out of the
ark have two brothers who were there but every was everyone was here and probably
were
adults so and we have four generations of kids and.
P.S. one fourteen my
parents and my aunts and uncles all went to P.S. one fourteen and I and
my brothers and sisters and all my first cousins and then my children and a lot of my nieces
and nephews and even a fourth generation my great niece and nephew who worked on
fourteen graduated and that's how we have a long history with that
school and then.
I think if I had to speak about the greatest memories I
have of this community in about the library itself is how much how
much I didn't
realize how good it. As for me
I don't like it reflected back to
life. And then
sort of realized that what I did
here to stay out of a whim out of a thought of saying this in that space and quite there let me
go over
there and how much that made a difference in the
entire circumstance of my life like it was a foundation
from this building.
I received a foundation that allowed me to build up my mind the mansion of the pivot.
So I was always very very appreciative of
that and very supportive of the libraries boss. I don't think the young people
really appreciate what's
here. Well give enough time to
it and you know in my day my mom had a six kids so I
pretty much had to do things
myself at some point to go so many children
today don't have the library.
They have parents are too busy to get them here and we have all these other distractions which
do nothing for you
educationally and sometimes I wonder if they even do anything for us at the payment
wise but that they have they're losing that great
opportunity to learn from the best place in the whole of
the fountain of education. It's not the schools. It's to
libraries and what we do after we finish with school.
Me.
And when I have to give anything I want to encourage our young people today.
And today I can say I have a lot of authority since I'm old. If I'm going to be
seventy years old next
year and that live a long life here spent almost all seventy of
X. and the entire seventy years of my life in Temple life within ten blocks of this building.
That I think if I have you any encouragement to
anyone it is take
time to really take time to learn.
I when I was very young I never considered myself a great reader but I would come
here every comic books. There was a book or classics are straight.
Now why did I do that was when I had a study to get back my time you had to take an exam you had to
do something and so on as classes as classic sources like the shortcut so if you
read the comic book version of Tom Sawyer like all the bad facts it was enough to get me
through a little I know to all of that reading I was only never
really got me to the point to have an excellent ability to
read. And I think that's the most
important thing that people can detect being able to read and being able
to write well is one of the most ingredients to
success. You can only talk so much they have to be able to do.
And your ability to communicate in writing.
And your ability to read in a stead.
What's before you makes the difference in how successful you are in your
life. Thank
you and. You're
welcome.